your platform has gotten really big so
there's some responsibility to that
weirdly big yeah yeah
um
let's say because like only a year ago
it was like a lot a lot smaller and then
it's hard to make that adjustment you
know because like to me it's just the
same it's the same show I've been doing
so how do you avoid becoming a GUI
yourself or uh you you go growing in in
um there's different trajectories you
could take one one of which is you can
start seeing everybody as a scammer and
only you can reveal it and like ever and
like you have a audience of people who
love seeing the Epic Coffee Zilla
grilling sure and you can destroy
everyone and that power now is getting
to your head how do you avoid that well
I mean this is like less optically
obvious I think the main way is like my
circle of friends doesn't care about any
of that like and my wife doesn't care
the people that whose opinion I value
has no relation to like a subscriber
metric or anything like that I think
that's like tangibly the most important
thing to just staying grounded as far as
like becoming a guru I just don't have
anything to like sell I mean I'm not
interested in teaching people Finance
I'm not interested in teaching people
I'm not interested in selling a course
and I've kind of given myself a hard
line on that which I think has helped me
a bit is there's a temptation to go well
I can tell what's a scam so let me tell
you what's not a scam and a lot of
people have offered a lot of money to do
that and basically be like hey I have
such and such legitimate product come be
like an endorser and I just don't do
that because I think it undermines a lot
of what I do is if you get like
if you're taking money and on the side
to say this is legit and you're saying
this isn't legit that's a huge conflict
of interest so I think it's about
managing conflicts of interest and
keeping people around me that are
grounded and also I think um
yeah my only Interest really is just
like make cool stuff and I guess I'll do
that until people stop watching so
a question from on that topic from the
coffee Zilla subreddit shout out shout
out how does coffee find the strength to
maintain his integrity and resist
temptation of being paid a great amount
of money to advertise or promote a
potential scam
uh I think that's like goes back to what
we've been talking about a lot which is
just on what you prioritize what you
value I've just never I guess I grew up
kind of lower middle class
and I had a great time like I had a
great childhood I had very loving
parents and because of that
I guess intuited at an early age that
money doesn't do a whole lot and I knew
a lot of people who were way better off
who had miserable childhoods
because whether their dad was always
gone at work or like they just had other
family issues that just money can't buy
and I realized
I I guess quickly
um that money's a very like it's a
glittery object that isn't what it
appears to be and so to me I'm like I'm
having the time of my life making my
show
I'm not gonna have the like I could you
could ruin all that just trying to go
for this quick check when it's like no
I'm having a great time like yeah it's
actually uh maybe you're probably the
same way but uh for me there's a lot of
happiness and having Integrity in
looking in the mirror and knowing that
you're the kind of person that has that
in fact walking away from money is also
fun
because it's it's like promising your
like it's showing it's easy to like just
say you have in Turkey it's nice to like
ha I actually I've discovered several
times in my life that I haven't
decorated
when you get put yeah you get put like
basically to the test
I I I've said like I don't know if I
publicly said but to myself I say like
you can't buy there's a lot of things
you can't buy with me like four billion
dollars like a trillion dollars
um but it'd be nice to get tested that
way it'd be cool to see because you
never know until you're in that room
it's true
um same with power given power I'd like
to believe I'm the kind of person that
wouldn't abuse power but you don't know
until you're tested so anyway I you're
in a really tricky position because
you're doing incred I mean you are a
world-class journalist straight up and
so there is pressure on that of like not
having like airing on the side of
caution with like having conflicts of
interest and stuff like that it's tough
It's a really tough seat to sit in
um it's really tough it's really tough
but it's unfairly tough I feel like
um but it's good that you're sort of um
weighing all of those but that said go
donate to coffeezilla donate all
everything support them it's a really
important really really important human
being